Schon wieder müssen wir eine katastrophale folgen des klimawandels vermelden die forschungsteams weltweit schon seit einiger zeit kopfzerbrechen
bereitet es geht um ein meeresgebiet vor alaska in dem sich zwei wassermassen übereinander stapeln und das schlimme
forschungsteams sind es tickende zeitbomben die das wetter ausgerechnet hier in deutschland massiv beeinflussen können pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Oben ist dieser meeres wirbel besonders kalt und leicht unten dagegen warm und salzig und forschungsteams sind sich sicher
dieser merkwürdige meeres wirbel ist eine tickende zeitbombe
wenn die konstellation instabil wird werden die wassermassen
nicht nur die arktis dramatisch verändern sondern auch das wetter hier bei uns in deutschland
konkret geht es um die beaufort see ein teil des nordpolarmeeres das vor alaska liegt die existiert ein
gigantisches strömungs system auch sofort wirbel genannt er dreht sich vor alaska im kreis und zwar im uhrzeigersinn
dieser merkwürdige wird mehrere wirbel besteht aus zwei sehr
unterschiedlichen wasserkörper die sich übereinander
stapeln die wassermassen oben sind zum einen sehr leicht und kalt es
sammelt sich eine art leichte wasser linse und genau dies sorgt dafür dass dort meeres als lange zeit im wirbel
festgehalten wird über jahre hinweg so das eis deutlich dicker und stabiler wird als in anderen regionen
diese linse verdeckt die tiefer liegenden schichten die salzig und warm sind die folge die arktis selbst zeigt sich trocken und kalt der
nordatlantik dagegen ist waren fest steht also dass die auswirkungen des meeres wirbel somit auch noch an den
europäischen küsten zu spüren sind zudem weiß man auch dass sich das verhalten des strömungs systems meist zuverlässig voraussagen lässt
seitdem es beobachtet wird hat sich sein zyklus etwa alle fünf bis sieben jahre
umgedreht dann floss das kalte leichte wasser plötzlich in den nordatlantik der zustrom des warmen wassers aus dem golfstrom
wird so langsamer und ganz europa kühlt sich ab ihr ahnt es was parallel
mit dem warmen tiefen wasser passiert es steigt auf und macht die arktis feuchter und wärmer doch eine
internationale forschungsgruppe hat jetzt eine spannende entdeckung gemacht demnach sammelt sich unter der linse aus kaltem leichten wasser eine um
das haben wohl messungen in der benachbarten region
chiemsee
gezeigt demnach hat sich der wärme gehalt der tieferen wasserschichten in den letzten jahren sogar
verdoppelt dieses meeresgebiet ist sehr flach und wird durch die sonne stark
aufgeheizt mittlerweile sogar fünfmal so intensiv wie noch vor 30 jahren und das hat folgen für
die süßwasser kappe der sofort sehen denn das warme salzige wasser sinkt darunter und punkt das tiefe wasser
mit wärmeenergie voll und das ist ein wirklich
waghalsiges konstrukt nach angaben des forschungsteams könnte das im fall der fälle zu fatalen konsequenzen führen angenommen diese
zusätzliche wärme würde an die oberfläche kommen könnte das gesamte meeresgebiet in dieser region eisfrei bleiben und das
könnt ihr euch selbst vorstellen hätte nicht nur kurzfristige folgen für die arktis zu diesem neuen
erkenntnissen kommt die tatsache hinzu dass sich der meeres wirbel seit fast 15 jahren seltsam verhält denn er dreht sich schneller und sammelt dabei
meersalz namens wasser am so gelangt immer mehr süßwasser in die kalte blase und so gelten
nicht nur die warmen wasser massen als tickende
zeitbombe denn das kalte wasser könnte auch extreme veränderungen bewirken und zwar einige tausend kilometer entfernt nämlich im
nordatlantik denn nach angaben der fachleute
würde dorthin das kalte wasser der ostsee fließen wenn sich die strömung umkehren würde so war es zumindest
in der vergangenheit doch da waren die wassermengen bei weitem nicht so gewaltig die heutzutage
und damit würde auch das wetter hier bei uns in europa und eben auch in deutschland dramatisch kippen denn dann wäre europa wohl
jahrelang vom golfstrom system abgeschnitten und eben auch von der tropischen wärme die
das system mit sich bringt sehr kalte winter wären die folge
das weiss man noch aus den 70er jahren durch ein ähnliches ereignis damals war der salzgehalt im
nordatlantik dramatisch gesunken und hatte für extrem kalte winter gesund da war es hier ganz ruhig in deutschland extreme kälte
wie in sibirien mit 7 -20 grad celsius legte deutschland wirklich lahmt das fazit der fachleute also ist erschreckend sowohl die
aufgeheizten wassermassen unter der süßwasser
diese als auch die wassermassen darüber könnten fatale auswirkungen haben nur dass andere regionen im fadenkreuz
dieser wasserbomben stünden das forschungsteam der aktuellen studie jedenfalls hat sich ist sich sicher dass der wirbel früher oder später
instabil wird und die bomben platzen und schließlich gelangen die wärme des tiefenwassers
zwangsläufig irgendwann einmal an die oberfläche der nasa-wissenschaftler
alec partie sagt für den beiden szenarien die folge in europa würden zwar nicht aussehen wie der katastrophenfilm the day after tomorrow
aber tatsache ist dass wir es einfach nicht wissen ob
so ein krasses statement wird man selten von einem wissenschaftler
also warum mal gucken was da passiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf kriegen nasa video schock
taktisches eis schmilzt rasant ja wenn er kein video mehr zu diesem und allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann folgt mir auf rezept dafür hier
klicken nur da bekommt ihr von mir vor allen anderen das neueste video ganz unabhängig von der abo box hier auf youtube
ja und trotzdem natürlich gerne auch ein abo da lassen und nicht die
immer auf die glocke vergessen bis dann
bleibt banken